I never felt like I could fully own my
label is it bisexual for a bunch of
reasons one when I was 11 or 12 I had a
crush on a girl and I told my friend and
she was like Ana you're just trying to
be interesting
so I have internalized that I'm just a
straight girl trying to be interesting
to bisexuality is a spectrum and for the
most part I mean my pie chart leans more
towards being attracted to men so it
felt weird to say I was bisexual if I
mostly felt attracted to men and finally
I'd never been physical with the woman
so how can you really affirm your
bisexuality if you've never gotten down
and dirty with the lady and then a few
things happened for one I talked to some
amazing queer women like Ashley Perez
and Gaby Dunn and Stevie Bobby who
basically said if you're attracted to
both sexes you're bisexual doesn't
matter where your percentages are it
doesn't matter if you've been with a
girl if you like both you like both and
then I was physically with the woman do
women at the same time my shoulder just
kidding I love and respect those women
very much and finally I got drunk and I
won an award at buffer festival and when
I was allowed to engrave this award I
did this and then I promptly sent it to
my parents because I figured it's easier
news to stomach for Asian parents if
it's engraved on an award and I always
thought I wasn't going to come out
publicly because for one I don't want to
get to monetize on YouTube and to
because I made this really embarrassing
video years ago about how it was okay
for me to kiss the same-sex when I was
in a relationship because end of the day
ain't gonna and trying to be really fun
but then I got drunk at the streamys and
won another award please please please
vote people need us more than ever
marginalized groups need us more than
ever I'm not only a woman of color but
I'm also a queer woman so please get out
to the polls and vote thank you thank
you very much so there you have it I can
only come out with my sexuality when I'm
inebriated and winning in some capacity
it's very anticlimactic anyway here's
what my parents had to say about me
being bi how do you feel well I'm not a
participant but none of my business I'm
open to it
I don't care thank you personally no no
not me I got a lot of cousins that
spins and gay so I grew up knowing about
it so there's no big deal
how do you feel about bisexuality no big
deal either I wish it ran in the family
did you really go out with a girl yes oh
I didn't know that so those song that I
kiss a girl I kissed a girl and I liked
it
that's true not really a little long as
they're nice as long as you're happy I
really don't care do you believe in
polyamory what is that I don't know what
that means I would have to believe it
from the fact that it exists in a lot of
cultures Mormons they have believed in
polygamy the Muslims believe in polygamy
and I've met quite a few on both sides
that are very happy with multiple
partners well if it works for them and
it's not my business I don't care but
you are monogamous meaning just one
person yes about it
I've already broached the question with
your mother that is not a topic for
discussion ever no no
this is for the record I have to say no
no but I did like my teacher before in
high school she's really pretty like her
but not like a bit I love the way your
face looks I have looked at men I
thought I bet women would literally like
him based on the way he looks but that's
as far as it goes no no I just want to
do it with Daddy and nobody else know
I'm kind of a little old fashioned I
think what do you think when I say
message I thought it was photoshopped
yes because I didn't think that's
something that they would present to you
on stage in front of the cameras and
much other people well I didn't get it
at first so I didn't know what the head
was like what is this be bi or what I
put the hat or a bi and that's why I was
like a sonic a bi daddy goes I don't
know surprised not really I mean not
that I suspected or anything but it
wasn't shocking I'm just like you
telling me about an address bye bye like
I said as long as you're happy I'm happy
for you don't you find a good partner I
think a partner that would love you take
care of you not hurt you
I think that's
that's all parents want for their kids
just to be happy we didn't mention it
you talk mean the mother didn't know
what it meant I kind of explained a
little bit did I have to go yeah no I
don't have to go that's the person it
doesn't matter if you're woman with a
woman over the guy you know I mean like
I said you just have to be in love
you're happy with them and as long as
that partner is good you know could beat
you good for you
and respect each other I don't see any
problem with it
[Music]
hi Timmy
[Laughter]